Hey there.
So I was thinking,
why don't you warm up by working on
the detail view for the shopping list.
I've been working on a detail view for
the shopping list object.
It's in the activeListDetails
package that I just gave to you.
Nothing is hooked up yet, though,
to actually display this screen.
Could you make it so that when you click
on the text of the shopping list right
here It opens up a detail
view of the shopping list?
And the name of the shopping list on
the detail screen should exactly match
the name of the shopping list
that you clicked to open it.
This should be a review of
some of the Android code and
Firebase skills that you learned
in version 0.1 of the app.
And actually, one more thing.
So I've been working on
a new workflow for us.
And basically how it's going to work
is I will describe a new feature and
I'll send you
the specification document.
And that document will include
my thoughts on the feature and
how exactly the feature works.
Also a couple of implementation
tips that I can think of.
I've written one for the detail screen
interaction that I'm looking for.
Care to take a look?